hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to insanity clicker now this
is a bizarre game it's actually has such
a unique
hey how's it goin there it actually has
such a unique premise that I just had to
play it
it's a clicker game like cookie clicker
clicker game what are you doing
can you stop jumping at me and you click
and click and click click click and then
they die and then you get presented with
a new monster and you keep clicking
thank you tooth and you keep clicking
until they all die and you progressively
get stronger and stronger as you go
through the game alright so basically I
just started the game I had to load in
because it wouldn't even give me an
exciting 's before I started playing but
sorry lady oh hey you look cool the
thing about it is I've been cycling
through some of the monsters some of
these monsters are like really
well-designed like I don't know what
this guy's story is but he is really
cool I mean a lot of these monsters it's
just bizarre and weird and apparently
they're part of your minded apparently
there's a whole meta game that further
expands what you do in this and I have
no idea what that is so we're gonna
explore it together but like I said this
game is free so why the hell not you
don't even look like a monster you're
just a normal person that was in the
wrong place at the wrong time
sorry okay you're a monster you're
definitely ran oh car Oh what are you oh
man I've been cycling through quite a
few enemies I haven't seen these guys
before this is weird
oh oh nice balancing on the sword act
too bad it's 200 what are you oh my god
is that's what's gonna happen to me in
50 years
when I become ingrained on the internet
and I just get absorbed into my computer
probably point oh no you're pregnant oh
I don't wanna know what with
hi oh you look relatively okay and
friendly oh you want a hug you want a
hug lady all right too bad all I have is
death oh that is oh oh I can get a
scorpion I don't know what I think it
just increases my damage oh I got a
Cobra Oh Oh my Cobra oh jeez no I don't
even get to talk to them anymore
hi okay ba okay so I'm gonna go up to
the next level now because I got this
new level in a while and I'm doing a
little too much damage so let's say hi
to the higher level guys and hopefully
get some more teeth out of it so you go
in the top bar you can see the numbers
play doctor welcome to the party why are
you ball and chain you married well
you're new these guys die so quick I
don't even know what the hell they are
all right whatever way these guys whoa
you look like the guy from Resident Evil
nightmare nightmare nightmare
oh I unlocked a new floor let's go up to
the harder one hi what are you uh Burton
oh hey Burton how you doing me no likey
that go away please thank you
they're like new monsters on every
single level whoa what are you whoa what
are you what are you what are you what
is that what is that to the right what
is that what is that
should I be worried about that or is
that okay I guess it's okay all right
bye buddy oh you're you're the same old
guy that we've seen before okay man oh
hello you look like one of the Silent
Hill nurses Joan Jane
that's your name Joan Jane all right
whatever
man oh no creepy little girl everybody
run away as fast as you can
my mr. Street uh sir berate er what's a
separator I don't know what a server
hello TV hacker is that really your name
TV hacker that's good name
good name buddy that's grandma oh how
you doing
whoo kyon gee with yours oh hey
Zachary of blows I didn't do that
oh look so friendly now you look so dead
oh my god oh you're okay
whoa hey boss look boss I should
actually probably help out about this we
could double-click in here for this oh
[ __ ] what do I just got a beat her up
over and over again oh wow that is a lot
of it's too much blood
oh all right okay then what happens if I
lose this boss do I just not get
anything out of it that locked sundew
well that's an awfully cheerful name for
what amounts to a horrible monstrosity
over there I don't think I want that see
what would the Scorpion do Oh
scorpion just does damage like
everything else I suppose all right I'm
gonna see what happens if I don't beat
boss to walk anything
oh hello harine harine what the hell
happened to me I don't know what you are
I don't know why you got glass why is
your weapon just this broken wooden
stool that's not gonna do anything to
anybody
oh hey buddy it's my old friend oh we're
going to next floor what are you
diabolic pentagram okay you look
interesting but I'm kind of interested
in like the environment that we're in
now also I seem to be traversing a lot
of this in siloam and I don't know how
much like there is to this place but
this is actually pretty cool
I have to admit for a free game this is
neato this is neato kebede Oh like I
appreciate the fact that they've made so
many of these garish foolish enemies
this is a huge variety of it oh and
always you and I need some upgrades that
create my bites okay have it in oh you
got whoa what are you well you're dead
okay oh you guys are so cool
Oh what are you that's so cool
look at that look at these monsters
ain't they adorable why am i collecting
their teeth that's another question that
I have to say I mean you obviously have
so many teeth in your head like how many
can you spare oh you probably got lots
of teeth have you got a spying weapon
whoa oh that was just a pride well I
mean a bride with a weird mouth in the
top of her head but a bride nonetheless
goodbye nog upendra man these characters
have weird names oh hi Frankenstein uh
Xena
well it's bizarre that some of the
female monsters in here are oddly sexy
with weird push-up bra outfits like this
one and the previous one
yeah well reminder complain oh god what
is going on here stop tormenting that
poor man faceless and Daddy isn't dead
okay hi what the [ __ ] Mary Helene what
are you doing you're not even my monster
you're normal except they're hanging on
intestines by the looks of it okay bye
whoa whoa a noon Tosca I don't hasta a
noon Tosca really a noon Tosca
how inappropriate with wheelchair
wheelchair wheelchair that's a my I just
feel bad why am i beating up a monster
in a wheelchair the game made me do it
Oh your new terror handler well with
your head I'm you tried to wear a bag
over your head but it didn't work dude
just cover it all up we don't want to
see it whoo flurry of blows I don't have
that yet I don't want that yet but I got
another Cober okay you're dead whoa
chest does that mean you have a treasure
can I have you know it was filled with
lies are your boss boss woofers are on
all right let's go for it
um and dare I go for the mythical
triple-click
not too much okay I got some cheese's my
god this poor guy of this emptying of
the entirety of his blood everywhere
pet unlocked Lilith that's not a pet oh
is that a doll okay what a Sun doodoo
okay just a lot of damage all righty
then okay next level hi welcome to the
forest I suppose prepare to die
hey I don't know why I was welcoming
myself to the forest because obviously
it's your home you're just a lot you're
just a tiger tamer you're literally
you're just an entertainer why am i
killing you Hannah or if it is your name
meow in some weird twist I don't know
I'm not hundred percent on this one what
that's climb
what are you doing with that poor man
whew okay bye whoa hey dirty trick er
Wow
why am I here and what happened to your
eyeballs and what a lovely balloon
you've got there how many people have
you killed
oh what's that oh thank you why was that
there I don't know why that was okay I
had to turn off the damage effects
because it was actually lagging my
computer so I'm just gonna do the
numbers for now and it was also getting
in the way of the monsters
whoa Nexxus left is that your name Lexus
flat have a good day Lexus I'd you're
gonna die flurry of blows first active
ability is available now I don't know
what that means hotkey one automatically
clicks 10 once a second for 30 seconds
oh nice nice nice killing it killing
them killing them dad that's a that's a
lot of that's a lot of active abilities
I mean honestly this is awesome flurry
of blows is over and 10 minute cooldown
hot tits okay I think we got another
boss after this so he'll blade or I'll
be with you in a second whoa boss Lord
croak boss Lord croak oh god am I gonna
beat this one I don't know if I can't
beat this one holy [ __ ] a [ __ ] damn and
I need like I should have I shouldn't
have wasted my flurry of blows okay now
I'm doing like double-clicking damage so
I think I should be able to go to the
next place so bring it on boss Lord crew
yeah this time I got ya
this time though
you better give me a lot of teeth after
this because if I don't get it oh holy
[Applause]
yeah okay got it
how many did they whoa that was a lot of
teeth okay so if I buy more of these bad
boys
another Lilith maybe it'll be fast
enough hacks and killing you alone
probably the best money is just farming
bosses but I don't know I think at this
point like my pets have far outpaced
what I can do by myself
because they seem they seem to be
killing these guys pretty dad pretty
capably alright what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna head unlock jesters chess I don't
have a hundred thousand yen let me get
the cyber worm first I'm gonna do two
things I'm gonna get to the next level
I'm gonna get the cyber world and then
I'm gonna unlock flurry of blows upon
the Blas upon the globe all along
whoa you look awesome awesome I can't
believe I'm still finding new monsters
it's got a thousand dps so that's a lot
of difference that's a lot of dippers
it's now 19 percent of my current total
of DPS whoa scorpion is 45% of my
current VPS that's awesome it's awesome
I wish it had a honey cam feature where
you could just click and hold like for a
slightly reduced speed but you know to
something so I don't kill my fingers
like I always do these clicker games all
right it's time for flurry of blows
bring it on boss oh god it's not enough
good boss hammer Vander I feel like this
game was made in Germany because all the
names seem to vary Germanic names
how about veal done yeah that's not
gonna work
even flurry of blows isn't good enough
man I have not even touched these
achievements holy [ __ ]
how are you supposed to get oh my god
what is it what does that mean what does
s mean those aren't no those aren't
those are numbers those are nothing
Oh God five hundred thousand five
billion 500 quintillion fifty thousand
quintillion I don't even know what that
is holy [ __ ] these numbers how can they
even get this I oh my god I'm just gonna
beat this one last boss and then I'm
gonna in the episode I've been playing
this way too long I did not expect to be
playing this this long it's weirdly
addictive just like cookie clicker is so
it's just kind of fun to play I don't
know why I don't know I don't blame you
don't judge me for this I'm gonna have
guilty pleasures to click and monsters
to death see in the occasional boob it's
nice okay so while that's farming for me
let's look through more of these
achievements cuz holy [ __ ] there are a
lot of Njemanze kill 10 bosses kill a
hundred bosses kill a thousand bosses
how are you supposed to kill a hundred
thousand bosses when I've only killed 32
give me that thank you I don't know why
the hell I keep getting those things but
thank you
maybe it's because I've been playing so
long damn it that's cool though thank
you for that I needed it and I'm gonna
upgrade Scorpio he seems he cool and
then hobo ski
now he's Wow every time I upgrade one of
these things they end up being my top
dps by a long shot
this should be enough I'm gonna beat
this freakin boss
oh this is gonna be close
oh I got to keep up the speed keep up
the speed keep up the speed my fingers
grab okay
god dammit that was hard
that was legitimately hard ow my hands
holy [ __ ] I think I need a break I just
need to let this game play itself for a
little bit
ah good god holy [ __ ] my hand oh but I
did it that's good
okay now I can get this boink all right
got that now that's doing 30% of my
damage a lot more than it was before
like it's undo up to 25 next then ha
Bisky
yeah now we're doing some serious Divis
I can't help you guys I can't help it
I'm gonna play up to 25 I want to see
the next boss
it's something about these flickr games
that like scratch that certain itch it's
like an illusion of progress it's not
really progress you're just fighting you
know up the numbers get bigger and
bigger but the numbers getting bigger is
its own reward so it's kind of cool in
that aspect so oh hey chest thank you
wow that's a lot of months that's nice
I've collected a million teeth good for
me I feel so accomplished whoo whoo that
sounds cool snake poison potency click
damage increase by 0.5 percent of
current DPS so that means that I'll
always have more I want that next
I want that definitely definitely death
almost almost and a little more little
more little more little more a little
more
ha Bisky and that'll do it and now my
blade damage is not all that much
increased but that allows for
exponential growth in the future I guess
so that was definitely worth it ok so
I've been playing for quite a while I'm
next to the boss this one's gonna be a
tough one because it's getting
exponentially more required to get
higher up in the scale but that's ok
because I'm about to get no I already
did that I'm about to get probably
Lilith up to 25 I think that's gonna be
the next thing that's gonna be most
beneficial to me ba bada ba bada ba bada
ba bada ba bada ba boink
okay and uh and then she's now doing 25%
this just means that we're doing a lot
more we're up to I see just look at the
numbers we're doing 96,000 VPS which is
hella good I shouldn't say the word
hella all right we can at least see how
we stand on the boss oh hello whoa
you're so cool looking but I'm nowhere
close to beating you I'm doomed ok screw
that Titan strength oh yeah whoa
increases your DPS by a hundred percent
okay if I do that and flurry of blows
and this little guy I think I can beat
the boss I'm pretty sure that's gonna be
enough to be able to smash everybody up
a storm
okay you ready here we go boink boink
boink give me give me the thing
[Music]
there we go
tell us riddle I don't know what that
means what does that mean what does that
mean what does a hellish ritual I don't
know but I'm doing this oh [ __ ] it's my
DPS gonna keep up long enough
Shaboom okay
hot damn that guy gave like half a
million half a million and we went up to
a roof sanctum okay so that's where I'm
gonna in this episode I've been playing
this for damn near an hour because I
have nothing better to do with my time
apparently but this is fun I will not
deny for a free game and for a clicker
game this is pretty cool there's a lot
of avenues of progression it's got a lot
of diversity to it pretty cool
okay deep knocker for Sammy Sammy
mortises oh god I gotta take advantage
of this okay so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this game there'll be a link in the
description below it's available on
Steam and thanks again for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
Oh